it's all about the image after weeks of
infighting among Germany's conservatives
Angela Merkel and hast Seehofer are
making a show of unity for weeks macula
to post zilpha's idea of transit zones
for Refugees on Germany's borders to
filter out migrants with little chance
of gaining asylum last weekend however
Makka gave in to the pressure within her
own ranks Venice I know nuttin Alec was
off this is a major task for our country
then that also means that we meet the
challenge together CD UNC as you are
ready to do so and we shall take
constructive approach in the coming
negotiations you think of a certain
unsexed we need to reach agreement on
this in fact we have to so that people
can see that all the parties in the
coalition are capable of action when
faced with a challenge of historic
dimensions other guy cause our
department collodion sinned in the law
gave in an a historian of garba to
handle but Merkel's other coalition
partner the Social Democrats still
opposed the central idea of transit
zones for Refugees once straight in esta
línea what bothers us most is that
refugees are held in detention as their
welcome that the first thing they see
when they arrived in our country is
something like a prison if we can find a
solution to this issue then I am sure
we'll be able to find a common position
Oscar Kosovo damned if you can see here
does fit once were standing and run on
Thursday all three parties meet again it
seems they still have a lot of
differences to settle